[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
uh if you're watching and uh
i tend to look shittier than normal if
you're listening and i sound shittier
than normal
it's because i got covered yeah that's
right folks i
uh uh i was vaccinated
and i still got covet but let me let me
tell you about there's this discrepancy
there's this
notion that wait a minute you get
vaccinated you shouldn't get that's not
that's not how it goes
it's it's it cuts down the severity so
if you get vaccinated
and you get sick you get covered you
won't have to go to the hospital you
won't have
a as worth of problems as you you would
if you know
if you weren't vaccinated so
all i'm saying is that it was
[ __ ] dude it was it was a tough week
um and uh
yeah i got it somehow i got it and um
i'm doing better so thank you for all
the messages
um it is no fun all i could tell you is
please
please get vaccinated i i don't i don't
care what your theories are i don't care
what you believe i got coveted and i'm
telling you
get vaccinated that's all i'm gonna talk
to you about that
you could do what you want all right uh
but it is
[ __ ] brutal great guest today
mr chris sullivan very excited about
chris sullivan this is us guardians of
the galaxy he and i did a
show uh a year ago a podcast together
and um it's so great having him back
and i think you're gonna really enjoy it
he had a baby and there's
so much fun to talk about um
so let's do that and uh hey i
couldn't do the stage it this last
weekend because i was sick
but this coming saturday rob and i will
be doing
a stage it will be doing our stage just
go to stage.com our band sunspin
we'll be playing two shows 2 p.m 6 p.m
pacific standard time
very excited uh about that sorry we had
to cancel for a week but i had
i just felt like [ __ ] so
uh stick around a lot lots to talk about
after the show
but uh why don't we just jump into it
let's get inside of chris sullivan
it's my point of view you're
listening to inside of you with michael
rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
i get a little teary-eyed when you
walked in i just forgot how much i liked
you
yeah seriously because we're pretty
comfortable
isolating yes and a lot of times
for me i'm like
it's just as easy for me to be like you
know what i'll just stay home
i'm just gonna stay home i know and at
least you but you have a wife and you
have a kid so you have reason to do so
reason but also excuse oh
to do so you know what i mean it feels
like an excuse
no but it can't somebody somebody said
you know when you have a kid
um you you
tend to miss out on some things that you
want to do
but you also have an excuse to not do
all those things you don't want to do
can't do it man the kid i have to stay
home
um people immediately understand that
and you compound that with the last
year's
uh global pandemic did you hear about
this oh i heard about that one um
and rachel and i would never have to
leave home ever again
which has been really you know the the
it's been nice and it's also it's good
to
get a call from you and say hey come
visit and then to be like
absolutely that's exactly what i want to
do so you need that
so you know well the first the first
thing i want to say is we have a segment
called you know it's a mental health
checking called how you doing
perfect it's perfectly tight there's a
jingle coming here comes how you
doing and it's just kind of like how how
are how are you feeling at this moment
how are you feeling in the last week
i mean you know because i know we go
through anxiety and we deal with a lot
of stuff and
you've got a lot of things compos you
know just piling up here
yeah i feel great really
yeah i'm so glad to hear that because i
thought you know because there's so much
i want to talk to you about that i
on the way over here i had one question
for you i said you know it's been a year
since we've seen each other
it has been almost exactly one year
that's just too much and i feel bad
about that i feel terrible about that
what are we going to do
well i could this is this is the thing
that we were we were
the world put us in that position and
that's and that's the way it is
but mike the one thing i want to know
from you is what you've learned in the
last year
what what have you learned in the last
year we don't have to get into it right
now i'm just saying get into it like
this is what i was wondering as i was
driving
i mean i bet michael has learned
some incredible things in this last year
i have i mean look when you're forced to
be by yourself
and you know with the exception of like
you know another person that i would
hang out with who we did an album
together which kept me going
it was some kind of like incentive to
get out of bed some kind of
but you need more than that so i i made
an album and
um that was really exciting it kept me
busy
but like not being able to hug people
not being able to see people for the
most part
uh you know and everybody dealt with
this and a lot of people dealt with
death and sickness and all this and i
dealt with some death i mean you know
my grandfather died right before the
pandemic then my
sister passed away last fall and then my
dog just died you know so i've had some
things
my god man but i know you know what you
know what's weird is
you know i don't really share it too
much i mean i share it on the podcast a
little bit but
surprisingly i'm sort of i was scared of
how i dealt with it because i dealt with
it pretty well
and i don't know if it's medication i
don't
i don't know what it is but like i don't
know if it's you know my sister was sick
for a long time so i think i was
mourning her throughout the years my
grandfather at alzheimer's for a year so
i was mourning him over the years
sure my dog was sick for a long time it
wasn't a sudden death
yeah and i think that i dealt with it
pretty good but i still
sometimes really want to cry and i feel
like i don't cry enough like i really
want to get it out
and i did this breathing exercise this
woman came over the other day
and it was breath work and i hadn't done
it so these things where it's like
oh yeah and i'm like oh my god she goes
listen we're gonna do this for 18
minutes straight i go
you're [ __ ] off i cannot do this right
team and
my hands got numb and she goes this is
all normal and then yeah all of a sudden
i started getting emotional
yeah and it was really weird and i think
it helped me so i said i want to see you
again it was a friend's wife and
yeah yeah she came over but it's those
things that i think i need to do that
would
sort of connect myself to the things to
loss to the things that i have dealt
with and
i i think because if you just bottle it
up i feel like you need some release
grief is a very interesting um
topic in our in american culture
we we don't uh value it
the same way other cultures do we don't
put an importance on grieving
the way a lot of uh other cultures do
and it leaves a lot of us feeling
[Music]
like what you're talking feeling that
that that feeling of of
i've skipped a step here you know what's
going on i've missed something
there's an important part of this
process that i haven't
that i that i haven't gone through yeah
that's it and
and it'll come have you dealt with a lot
of death
uh i haven't you haven't you have your
mother and father
yeah and and my i had one grand
grandparent
until i was one grandparent left when i
was born
they they had all passed before i was
born and
wow and so i've only dealt with the
passing of one grandparent
i've dealt with a lot of death in the
last year you know as far as
people passing uh from kovid yeah um
but nothing immediate in my life does
that scare you because it scares me when
you know oh my god if i i can't imagine
losing my you know and i'm not
incredibly close i love my parents but
like i would go i would go nuts if i
lost
any sibling or any family member and
that's like i'm getting to the age where
it's like
yeah [ __ ] starts to happen you hear
people die in their fifties
in a lot of my contemplative practice in
my meditation or my prayer i
actually do imagine that i spend time
imagining what it will be like or what
it would be
almost pre-grieving pre-grieving but
also
loading my gratitude and front loading
my um
my approach to the relationship with
these people you know if i've spent
enough time wondering what my life would
be like without my mother my father my
wife
my my son which i have
there yeah spent very little time
delving into that but
you know we recently learned
of somebody who had lost their son and
and to to to imagine that and to um
to grieve in a way uh
uh improves my life
so much because i because i when i see
this person my heart
is just when i see you you know to go a
year without seeing you and then to see
you
yeah you know the gratitude rushes back
in i open the front door and i hear you
upstairs playing the guitar and singing
and i'm just like i didn't even know you
were here
well i the door was unlocked i i you're
always welcome to walk in but i didn't
i was playing guitar and i was just
feeling it and playing it like and my
heart just
my heart left for you my friend because
we would get together before we did our
old podcast together and we would play
music and
we play a song i play a song and uh it's
a beautiful thing yeah
so that's how i'm doing i'm doing all
right it's been it's been a
contemplative year
it's been um it has been uh
a good year because rachel we started
the pandemic on vacation
we were literally on vacation had to
come home rachel was
six months pregnant we spent the last
three months of her pregnancy in
quarantine
we spent the first six months of of or
three or four months of bear's life in
quarantine then i went back to work on
this is us
and and we managed to navigate an entire
season of television with with nobody
getting
sick in our cast extraordinary which was
i mean statistically incredible
um and so it's been it's been a real
like
we r rachel and i've really had to turn
towards each other because
every time we turn around there we are
like okay so what are we gonna do with
this time
and how are we gonna how are we gonna
push through um
maybe some of the sticking points you
know of our of our relationship and it's
been
it's been really really [ __ ] hard
yeah and
and really beneficial i'm shocked it's
not that i was hoping you'd come in here
and you'd say [ __ ] oh my
but i thought you know i know chris and
you know he gets anxiety
he deals with he has this you know he
has an anxiousness that i have and he
deals with certain demons
and um then i go we'll add into the
equation
a new baby boy and add an equation the
show
this is us just was uh cancelled well
not canceled it's always been
that's well they've been saying cancel
but it just hasn't it's as if season six
is always
so next year this yeah right the next
season will be the last season and that
is where dan fogelman has always wanted
to end
so you always knew this show was gonna
end after six seasons yeah
yeah i mean i don't know if i believe
you no no
we've all he says that but as a creator
you can only go so far because the
studio might jump in and say no we want
another season
oh so you probably were thinking sure
we're going to get another season
if he doesn't want it we were maybe we
were hoping maybe we were hoping
right or maybe i thought it was the
greatest negotiating tactic of all time
on dan's part for you know at season
three being like no no i only want to do
so it's a jedi mind trick yeah
um no no because he's told us the ending
of this show we know the ending you know
the ending we know how the ending
do people die um i mean everyone dies
michael
that's an ambiguous answer well i mean
but that's the kind of the point of
of the show is
it goes back and forth in time to show
you a time before
people are born and a time after people
are dead
and and the fact that the world
continues and these relationships
continue
um and i know this we've already shot
scenes
from the final episode did you cry i
wasn't part of them but we the the the
production has
has captured scenes for the final
episode
did people cry people cried yeah people
people cry people always cry it's this
is will you cry
you you're not done filming no we have a
whole we have a whole another season
you have a whole other season shoot yeah
to shoot oh well [ __ ] i mean then that's
not
that's not cancellation that's a whole
season to go here no that's what i mean
that's what i'm saying how many episodes
18 more to go 18 more to go do you
already start thinking about your next
job
you know what i do yes
there are there are things i'm i'm
trying to put into the lineup
for a year and a half from now um but as
you know
that that is always a guessing game um
but i do know this i've never been
sentimental for the ending of things
because i it doesn't it doesn't ever
feel like an ending
you know it doesn't like the ending of
our podcast i was like
okay this only means that that that
things are about to evolve
right and something will happen into
something bigger and we'll work together
in something look
this podcast room is now a full-blown
production studio
and your podcast went to the next level
and obviously i
i had a child and and um
i've i've been that way since high
school you know the theater production
ends and all the kids gather around and
they cry and they're so
you don't get like that i don't i don't
and i don't know why
it's not it's not i i get like that too
i don't like i always want things to end
my thing is i want things to end which
is not a good thing right i have good
things happen i mean i'm like
i wish it's the whole actor thing it's
like i just want a job i want a job i
have a job when do i have off
when do i have you know what when do i
have off when is the show going to end
okay we've done it
and i always feel like i think it was
with my 80d it's like it's like after i
do a pilot episode i'm like god that was
great i'm good
or no you have a whole season left right
really there's a creative side of
of of what we do obviously and then
there's a business side right
and you and i are uh it's hard for a lot
of people to understand like i am my
product
right i am what i am selling to to a
tv show to a movie to a whatever i
i say to a production here's the value i
bring
to to your product right right and then
that creative work is something that
happens kind of in another
section of my brain but for this
wonderful thing like this is us to
happen
to the cast and to the creators and to
myself
in order for it to mean anything it has
to end
like in order for it to in order for me
to
take this wonderful occurrence in my
life out into the world
and parlay it into more creative
collaboration and
more um creative challenge
it has to end that's a very positive
ryan put the microphone to your mouth
for god's sake
writing that down hold on that was good
what do you think about that i think
that's great i mean ugh
geez i really thought about it like that
do you think like like you know
everything has to end do you have a
healthy attitude like that or do you you
have the approach where you're like i
don't want this to end
i'll be devastated if it ends i need
this to continue uh i mean i think
having a sense of finality is definitely
preferred for me um
because then because i like having
things done so then i can move on to the
next thing so that it is not just sort
of hanging there and then you sort of
know
okay that thing is done and now it's the
next i mean it applies to like work
for me uh yeah and just like just like
like i need like in just like even
day-to-day activities like
uh i just need the thing to be done so
then i can do the next thing and then
the next thing
and i can't do the next thing until that
first thing is that because
it is the reality of ever everything
ends right so
understanding that uh is
is only beneficial for me
you know i think the most important
thing is and i struggle with this is
just enjoying the time you have before
it ends
there's a beginning and then there's
enjoyment and then there's the end
and then it's it's sort of like god i
was [ __ ] on the you know
my old therapist who i fired can you
fire a therapist
yeah okay i remember he stood up like he
was standing up like he was taking a
piss
and he goes you got one foot in the past
your right foot's here in the present
and you're pissing on the future or no
you got one foot in the past one in the
future and you're pissing on the present
and he had his you know showing you like
now and a lot and he had pulled his
pants down he didn't pull his pants down
that would have been appropriate and
you're like that's it you're fired
although for him it might have been
appropriate because that was the kind of
guy
that was the kind of guy who i'm sitting
there and he's eating a subway sandwich
and he's just devouring
his do you mind if i eat i'm like yeah
it's my hour i'm paying you a lot of
money
and he's like oh i didn't say that yeah
sure he's like mm-hmm mm-hmm
mm-hmm okay yeah this is over zoomers oh
this was uh this is
years ago i let him go after that i felt
like you know what this is we're too
comfortable he's too calm he's too
comfortable i'm uncomfortable
this is not comfortable yeah you're
you're shooting with the bathroom door
open now yeah
but do you enjoy the moment are you
going on set every day and enjoying the
days
i have gotten better at it and i've
gotten much better at it
since bear arrived bear your son bears
my son bear sullivan what's his middle
name maxwell bear maxwell
i was kind of lobbying for maximus
but it was too bear bear sullivan yeah
i think of like this is comes mine
and starting linebacker number 32 bear
maxwell
the 265 foot six five senior from
you know absolutely absolutely is he is
he big for his age
that's he's 10 months old and he's
wearing 18-month clothing
so he's he's he's very large for his age
but the the since he since he has
arrived
all the paradigms have shifted in out in
us in an instant
and it's been very difficult to um to
realign
and to ground myself in the new reality
uh
that is everything and that includes my
work and i haven't figured out how to
express this yet i keep talking to
people about it hoping that each time i
talk about it it will
uh coalesce in my brain as a coherent
idea but
but i
i just don't care about anything else
anymore
really it's bare and then there's a big
something in between and then everything
else there is my relationship with
rachel
there is my love for bear really bear
doesn't exceed
rachel um no i don't i
i don't that's a tough one it is
it is a tough one but i also i think
it's important for bear as he grows up
to see that
to see that my love for rachel
is the reason for his existence you know
is that the foundation of everything but
but what i mean is
and and when i say i don't care it
sounds negative it's just
the importance of these other things in
my life
have fallen away and the the anxiety
around showing up for a big scene
is gone and what has happened is i can
just show up for the big scene
really it's been insane michael the
that anxiety that we used to talk about
is just
not there because bear is the most
important thing to you this this
creature this cr
thing that you created with rachel and
all of a sudden you're
telling me this little child brings you
so much joy
and importance that everything else
seems not trivial but just not less
important see this thing i don't know
how to explain it's not that things
become trivial it's not that they're
unimportant it's not that i don't care
it's it's the anxiety
that i used to put on them the
narcissistic anxiety
that i used to put on other things on
events on my work on
uh what other people think of me it
has just evaporated melted away really
and for the first time in my life i've
been able to actually maybe
look at my work this last season and
say i think that's some of the best work
i've done
on this show and i feel
feel confident and comfortable talking
about viewing my own work
looking at it and going wow you did a
good job that was good chris
that was a that was a that would say
you know what i mean like i i normally
have a lot of criticism i have
and it's not even negativity it's just
analytical okay look at that see the way
you did when when the camera is on your
on that side and and and below your eye
level you need to be
hyper focused on things that aren't
really that important and are just
causing you anxiety right
inside he was brought to you by me
undies i don't think i've worn anything
more comfortable than me undies it's
like um i might as well be wearing
nothing
it honestly feels like i'm free balling
with these guys
me undies feels just so comfortable i
got the boxers
and i'm telling you man it's just
i feel groovy i feel
just smooth i don't know what else to
tell you guys got to try these this
underwear
you got to try it you're going to thank
me for it because you know how
much i love comfort so if you're
listening to me and you're like
rosenbaum wouldn't lie to me
you got to grab these look me undies
believes that comfort is more about
than what's touching your skin it's
about feeling comfortable in your skin
that's why me undies not only uses
sustainable breathable
soft as heck fabrics but they also give
you endless styles to choose from it's
total comfort
inside out meundies offers classic
colors to ridiculous prints it's all so
you can fully express yourself in your
own unique way
me undies are available in a range of
sizes from xs that's
extra small to 4xl
they got us all covered here i'm telling
you never leave your couch again with a
me undies membership now this is pretty
damn cool
a monthly subscription that sends new
pairs right to your door
each month you'll choose new undies
socks
or a bralette and pick the style and
color or print that feels the most
fun the most you
right plus enjoy discounted pricing free
shipping
and exclusive early access to new
launches
love your butt and get the membership me
undies also has a great offer for my
listeners
for any first time purchasers you get 15
off and free shipping me undies also has
their problem free philosophy okay
listen to this if you're not satisfied
fully
with any product for any reason they'll
refund it or exchange it
no caveats no questions asked to get 15
off your first order and free shipping
go to meundies.com
inside that's me undies m-e-u-n-d-i-e-s
dot com slash inside me undies
dot com slash inside inside of you is
brought to you by better help
better help online therapy i mean these
guys have been with me quite a while
because you know what it works
uh ryan is not here with us today he he
gets better help i have other friends
that get better help
better help is really changing people's
lives i think the stigma of going to
therapy
i think that's going away now people are
starting to realize that hey
i want to live a better life i want to
enjoy my life i want to join my family
enjoy my friends i don't want to keep
things
you know tucked down deep inside the
cause of stress and depression and all
these other things
as we begin to see the light at the end
of the covid tunnel
a lot of people are still feeling down
and emotionally out of sorts
you may not feel depressed or at a total
loss but if you're feeling a little bit
off or your relationships are suffering
it could be a sign you should talk to
somebody so online therapy
can help and it will help all you got to
do is fill out a questionnaire to help
better
help assess your needs and match you
with your professional
licensed therapist start communicating
with your therapist in under 48 hours
schedule secure weekly video phone or
even live chat appointments
therapists have a broad range of
expertise that may not be locally
available in your area
but all you do is log into your account
anytime send a message to your therapist
betterhelp is committed to great matches
so it's easy and free to change
therapists if you need and that's so
important if you don't
vibe with them right away you think oh
that's it i tried no no no we'll get you
a new therapist betterhelp will get you
one
right away and sometimes it takes a
minute to get comfortable with the one
that you
want to be comfortable with um you have
to be comfortable and have to like the
person you're talking to and trust them
and that's very important so
we'll get you the right one better help
is more convenient and more affordable
than in-person therapy and financial aid
is available let me tell you something
for someone who went to uh a therapist
especially here in la
uh it's it's so much more money than
better help you it's bonkers how much
more expensive it is better help is so
much more affordable
and that's a huge reason i love them too
our listeners get 10 percent off their
first month at betterhelp.com
inside that's better h-e-l-p-com
slash inside betterhelp.com
inside for 10 off better help
inside of you is brought to you by geico
we all know what i'm going to talk about
right now so don't you be fast
forwarding this
all right i mean geico makes life so
much easier on me and i know it's gonna
make it easier on you
if you if you listen if you're paying
homeowners insurance
renters insurance auto policy why pay
three different people they have a
bundling policy they take care of all of
it it's so easy with geico
even a rosenbomb can do it guys go to
geico.com
get a quote and see how much you can
save it's geico easy
visit geico.com today that's geico.com
even a rosenbaum can do it but you know
what's funny
is this conversation right now i feel a
little narcissistic because i feel like
i'm now i'm thinking about me and i'm
thinking subliminally
are you telling me to have a child
is that what you're getting at um no i
mean but look
i mean my grandmother always says he
goes mikey you'd be such a great grey
off great father you're so good with
kids and you know i think once you my
grandfather used to tell me it makes me
sad that he never got to see me as a dad
but and i don't know if i'm going to be
a dad but he's like you know family's
the most
important thing in the world once you
have a family mike everything else just
it doesn't matter your family is the
most important thing in my grandma you
would be such a
and i think wow and so i've been i went
where i i was in those stages where i
wanted a kid and then i was stages were
like you know what the [ __ ] i can't even
take care of myself
and then i thought you know maybe having
a kid
would really just
there's that that kid becomes the center
of attention that's your main focus
and maybe that's sort of what you need
not to have a kid
as a as a test to see well that didn't
work sorry buddy
i'm still the center of attention so go
get yourself a beer
uh you know it's not like that but you
know i'm starting to think if i do meet
the right
person if i have the right thing you
know maybe if that works out because you
and rachel had a strong bond
and you've been through thick and thin
and i know you went through you know you
went through ups and downs and kind of
like it's that's the relationship
and then you get it together and then
you have this child and that's that's a
great thing and that doesn't always
happen usually it's either
a lot of times it's an accident or i'm
getting older i need to have a baby
and that's what the wrong person right
right so i don't know i
now it occurs to me that maybe maybe it
could be a good thing for me actually
family
it's it's it's let's put it this way
it is a a surefire way well that's not
even true
it was a surefire way for me to enter
the second half of life
you know the first half of life i spent
building up this persona and this ego
and this container and now i've entered
a a section of my life where i figure
out what goes in that container
what i want to fill it with what um
the purpose is um for
for myself what what type of impact do i
want to have on the on the world around
me um
and what type of values do i want to
instill
and pass along to this new person who is
going to have his own
uh his own path and his own struggles
and his own pain
and his own anxieties um
and can i can i uh
die into myself enough can i kill my ego
enough
to get out of the way and
and help be an emotional
coach or an emotional support a mentor
for this new being now look yeah you're
making it sound like look obviously this
is
fantastic but you'd be kidding yourself
not to say it it
can't be easy i mean so far it's pretty
easy because really
well he he doesn't communicate yet so
that's gonna be the hardest thing i wish
i knew what you wanted what's the matter
why are you crying
well when he cries it's very it's very
brief
okay you're lucky you're one of those
parents who have the first kid and
they're an angel and they have a second
kid and it's damien from the old woman
of course
and and he he let's put it this way he
can't speak yet but he can't
he does communicate very well he he
he fusses when he needs something and
usually he only needs
one of three things you know food sleep
or or or a new set of clothes
um and that's easy that that part's easy
so what has been difficult is is bear
requires my constant attention
when he is not sleeping even when he's
sleeping
which means that whatever i'm doing
you know worrying about the future
regretting the past
running around busying myself
i'm constantly being brought back to the
present moment that ceases that's that's
done that doesn't cease
it like it like fires you know ac dc
alternate current it like
okay right okay here okay i can focus on
now i'm immediately brought back to the
moment is that frustrating
no it well it was at first because i
would get i would get
frustrated with myself i would get
impatient and then i just realized
aha this moment this is this is all
there is
is this moment and so bear is just here
reminding me of that
come back come back come back come back
to this moment come back to now
okay yeah take care of that and come
back uh yeah you can worry for a second
your your my mind can wander for a
minute but there's this child
you know and and it at first it was
frustrating and then i just realized
where else where else would i where else
could i go where else do i want to be
than right here right you know that's
been a big part of the paradigm shift is
you know when
when you call and you say hey come over
to the house hang out let's do a podcast
i have to think to myself is that two
hours
that i want to spend away from bear wow
like so the answer was yes the answer
was yeah
well the answer is the answer is is this
going to feed feed me
in a way that makes it valuable enough
to be away from bear sure you know and
it's healthy
to it's you still have to do things you
go to work you do this there's still if
you thought for a second i'm not
spending enough time with my child you
wouldn't be here
that's right and the the lesson the
lesson that we've
that i've i learned over the the the
panda i don't know about you
but during the pandemic i was busier
than i'd ever been
right at home you know
because everybody knew you're at home
right you're not going anywhere i know
you don't have anything to do
so would you mind hosting this virtual
gala for my charity like
you know what i mean like and of course
i want to engage with the world i want
to be helpful i want to be of service
but i was saying yes to everything
really yeah and i and i realized because
you're a good guy
well yes mostly i mean mostly i mean you
are a good guy you you you
i try to be but what i did realize is
that i sometimes i was doing things that
were outside of my
um sorry jason sorry jason
um voorhees yeah that was sorry
for those people not watching yeah i
just elbowed jason in the face yes
um you know i was i was i have to get
rid of this [ __ ] by the way if i had a
child they have all these horror movies
jason voorhees head
i can keep this seat through no i don't
know we've talked about the hor they're
valuable lessons in horror movies yeah
uh the i was committing to things that i
didn't have the energy for
and so by the time i was i was
doing them i was already resenting them
and that's not
that's not the way i should move through
this world
and if i have committed to something i
need to get my head on straight
and take care of my own resentments and
and move through it
you know present in the moment bringing
all of the energy that i have
you know come over here and come over
here and what lay around on the couch
you know i'm not uh i don't know what's
his name
who your last guest was just laying
around oh joe mchale well if he i don't
know if he'd be the
last guest but joe mchale did lie around
no he was a big guy and i asked chris i
said chris you know
feel free to lie there and then you know
of course ryan would have to sit on a
stool
yeah and which is fine but nobody did
for his corner nobody puts ryan in the
stool
yeah um my ass appreciates it yeah
but you know you invite me over and and
i want to show up
and be here right but isn't that an
isn't it
what you're talking about with with bear
isn't it an analogy for
life imagine just every situation
is bare like if i i organize a softball
thing on sunday
go for two hours and play softball and
give softball and your friends attention
right for two hours right and then go
off and do something else but everything
you do
should have that sort of attention your
work your love life your
the dishes that it does it doesn't just
be in the moment that is the key to what
we have been
talking about from our last podcast that
we did to this podcast
to to somehow just being in the moment
and that is
very hard for me i'm almost ahead of
myself
and i'm working on that and and what i'm
saying is the only thing i have ever
come across
that that that brings me back into the
moment without fail
every time is bare see and that didn't
happen before you didn't have that thing
to bring you back i had to work really
hard
i had to work really hard do you work as
hard you think do you think everybody on
that show obviously you're going to say
yes everybody works hard do
everybody has different work ethics when
you're doing this as us
do you see that some people are just so
like there's some people that are the
method that you just you know you don't
want to be around them because they're
just
so hyper focused they need to stay in
the moment the whole day they're just
and then there are other people who are
just like anyway oh my gosh chrissy your
voice is
you know do you other people on the set
like that everybody's different i mean
it depends on the day you know
i have i have a good deal of respect
for for what's going on that day
there are certain days that are much
heavier than others
right you know and i can be the same way
if i know at the end of this day
i'm gonna have to have a panic attack
nervous breakdown
on camera i'm not going to be goofing
around all day
the way i normally would right you know
i need to have something
to preserve that energy preserve the
energy kind of focus the mind
um it doesn't mean that i i need to be
and i've and i've learned this
because it doesn't mean i can be rude to
other people it doesn't mean i can be
snippy with other people and i've let
those things bleed over in the past
where i'm so focused on my work and
somebody comes up and asks what
i i don't yeah i can get short i get
right and that's inappropriate
everyone on our show is very good
about being
present for the work that they have to
do and
and letting it go when it's done and
being respectful to each other yeah
there are certain people who
everyone works like you said everyone
works very hard
some people make it look a lot easier
justin hartley is the most effortless
he's the most effortless actor i've seen
and i'm sure
that the wheels are turning and i know
he puts the work in and i know
he has his you know routines or whatever
it is
but when he shows up it is it is
the most effortless thing i've ever seen
you know who i think is probably the
most intense and he's such a great actor
and this is this is a
it's a good thing but i picture sterling
oh yeah being
very like hey i love you all but don't
[ __ ] with me
he doesn't even have to say that he he's
just he is focused and he is a
technician
when it comes to emotion like we've
talked about he can
he can if the camera's on the left all
right i'll make sure the tear comes out
the left eye
you know like really he could do that i
don't know if he can do that it
certainly appears that way
it's like it's just it's crazy to me wow
and he
shows up and he he brings the energy
to the set he is he is amped up he is
ready to go
and he the the best thing about our set
is that nobody has to say stuff like
that
everybody gets it who has it the
toughest who do you think has
mandy mandy has it the toughest man
because mandy has played
everything from her as herself from 16
years old to 90.
and she so she spans every
generation of this tv show so she is on
set
more than anyone and she's emotional
yeah she's in every timeline
she has to play most often
a 65 67 year old woman
and she does an incredible job she is
the most overlooked person
on our show because she is so ever
present i think i think
her lack of nominations for awards and
things boggles my mind because the work
she's doing
is better than anything else on on
network television right now wow it's
it's it's insane and and her level of
emotionality
is she upset by that do you think she
gets upset by that i think she would
we look we all would like the
recognition
emotionally spiritually whatever it is
for the work that we do
sometimes well but also like we were
talking about you know that type of
recognition
um ups our value for the business side
of this
of this job so nominations and awards
because you were nominated for an emmy i
was dinklage
dinklage think let's beat him
son of a bee um but those those things
add to your value in this industry so in
order
to do six years mandy to do six seasons
of some of the best acting
i've seen on tv you know she wants to
she wants that to roll over into other
things and she'll be fine she's oh
she's an incredible actor an incredible
singer but um
she definitely has it the hardest on our
show who
cries the most chrissy chrissy cries the
most
and she's a good crier she's a very good
crier she well
she she has the thing that makes her
such a brilliant actor is that she has
access her emotions are on call
like they are right below the surface so
if she needs them
they're they're ready right and i can't
say that for myself
like i have like i said i respect how do
you work into it
to an emotional scene where you have to
cry do you do you constantly
think or dwell on like [ __ ] i've got to
cry i've got to cry i've got to cut
give me glycerin i've only given me
glycerin spray blister in my eyes i've
done glycerin in my eyes before
i don't give a [ __ ] i've done it all the
the i've only had to do it once
on this is us right um it happened
uh spontaneously a second time
and then the rest of the time i've kind
of made the the choice
not to for that not to be a path for me
chrissy
chrissy has that path uh uh that emotion
that emotional level
sterling has that emotional level we
can't all be we can't all be crying you
know right yeah
but you all are but you know
but you know what i mean like like so so
i've i've
yeah i've avoided it probably
mostly for my own comfort level and ease
yeah it's kind of when you see a scene
where like i gotta get emotional i gotta
cry is it kind of like [ __ ] um yeah i
mean
it's work you know it's getting extra
it's gonna be a long day it's gonna be a
long day it's not fun
and how long do you shoot like a scene
before you get it usually do they really
just milk it
i mean it's tv it's network tv we're
moving you know you you've done it so
but you're doing three or four hours a
scene
at least yeah four hours of scene yeah
so you're gonna do a close-up a mid-shot
a wide shot
their coverage that's the other thing
yeah if you have to be emotional can you
do it
15 times and by the way do you prefer
doing an emotional scene with the camera
having it on you at first just so you
don't lose that
um it's been
yeah yeah probably that's better because
at the end you're giving everything
and then you turn around and you get
nothing left yeah has that ever happened
to you
yes early on when i didn't quite realize
the structure of television i realized
oh well
i i gave everything i had you know
while the camera was pointed at oh my
god i gave everything then the joke
michael what a great performance that's
the camera's not on you yeah and then
they turn around i'm like i don't know
guys i don't even know the lines anymore
i don't know what i'm doing and they're
like what happened to him i don't know
that's happened before i used to be the
guy that they go uh
we've got 30 minutes left you know uh
we'll just go we'll turn around
rosenbaum for the last 10 minutes for
his close-up and he's got all the
dialogue
he'll do it he'll be a professional and
i get so upset i'm like
i'm stressing my ass out because you're
going to turn around on me at the end of
the night when we're all going home at
like 11 00
at night or one in the morning yeah and
they would turn around on me and tom
would be like hey you need me i'm like
yes stay here
inside of you is brought to you by
hellofresh i'll tell you what what if
you can make
delicious healthy meals and you can put
to put them together and it's already
put together for you all you have to do
is
sort of cook them yeah so someone says
oh i want to make
chicken cacciatore sounds complicated
well i wouldn't even know how to do it
you look at a recipe book and then you
gotta go buy all these different things
and you got to put them together and
what if all these things were right
there for you that's what hello fresh is
with hellofresh
you get fresh pre-measured ingredients
mouth-watering seasonal recipes
delivered
right to your door skip trips to the
grocery store and count on hellofresh to
make
home cooking easy fun and affordable and
that's why it's america's
number one meal hellofresh offers 50
menu and market items each week
including ready to eat
salads sandwiches and soups try hello
fresh's quick and easy meals 15 to 20
minute dinners breakfast on the go and
more easy options perfect for your busy
lifestyle i love hellofresh because they
make
it easier i feel like i'm uh doing
something i can actually make a dinner
but it's all right there for me
it's healthy it's ready it's delicious
hello fresh
there's not much more to say other than
get hello fresh
make your life easier enjoy your life
just go to hellofresh.com
iou14 and use code
iou14 for up to 14
free meals plus free shipping
it doesn't get greater than that folks
listen again
go to hellofresh.com iou14
use the code iou14 for up to 14
free meals plus free shipping
it doesn't get better than that
hellofresh try them
you'll love them inside of you is
brought to you by
untuck it summer is here folks and
there's never been a better time to try
a shirt from
untuck it they have performance shirts
that wick sweat
how many of you are sweaters out there
huh how many do you how many of you out
there sweat
we all sweat and untuck it also has
short sleeve button downs polos they're
made to beat the heat
untucked shirts are perfect as we
transition back to the things we've been
missing
like dinners with friends reuniting with
families and vacations too
and look they make shirts designed to be
worn untucked how many of you have seen
these guys
i was one of them at a party or a
barbecue
and their shirts they're trying to wear
a button-down shirt and it's down to
their knees
because they're designed for slacks you
know to be tucked into your slacks
for god's sakes man untuck it is where
it's at they have fits for all shapes
and sizes
untuck it offers up to triple xl
plus they have slim relaxed and tall
fits untuck it has 85 stores nationwide
and get this free returns and exchanges
you gotta get some shirts from untucky
check out their supply
you're gonna love them i have at least
10 shirts that i own
use code inside for 20 off your first
purchase
at untuckit.com 20
off by using code inside
20 percent off your first purchase at
untuckit.com just use the code
inside do you want to do something
funnier lighter do you want to do
something like the nick
something what is it you would like to
do if you had the choice to do it after
the show i'd love to get into some
some straight comedy yeah yeah it's been
a long time
well i got a show i'm working on oh how
about that
yeah i got the road just for you you're
gonna play the mandroid
that's the characters i'm in i'm ready
i don't care what the rest of it is that
sounds great that sounds just wonderful
uh i know you're doing tons of music are
you still working with taylor goldsmith
from
dawes yeah i mean we released that
record halfway through the pandemic you
know
you you were in the same boat
congratulations on birthing that by the
way yes
jesus spouse though the album's awesome
and and thank you and thank you and by
the way
he's a big dawes fan oh very cool oh
yeah yeah
they're they're incredible cause i said
you know he's working with tyler he goes
taylor
goldsmith i go yes from dawes you know
i love the way he writes i really love
like the because it almost feels like
punch lines in a way but like they're
just like really like he like he really
sets it up and then like the final rhyme
is like oh
jesus dude yeah he he is one of the
great living american
singer-songwriters and when i first met
him
um through mandy right yeah they were
just dating and
it was early on in season one or two of
this is us
and he said i got this band called dawes
and i don't know how this band escaped
me
up until four years ago but i went home
and i and i
bought all their albums every single
album and listened to them
in chronological order and
would text him as i was listening to
songs when something would come to me
and i'd have a question
okay track four uh your second album
and and it was that writing style that
you're talking about ryan that
that a a bell went off
for me yeah and i was like this guy
listens to a lot of john prine
and i just knew it and i texted him and
said i said you listen to a lot of john
brian don't you he said yeah yeah how'd
you know i said
because of this lyric and it was one of
these punchline
really intelligent witty it's like a
little bit of everything is that one
song
where it's like he's telling three
different stories right and i think the
best line he'd ever written was uh
it's um things happen that's all they
ever do
right that blew my [ __ ] mind yeah
things happen that's all they ever do
it's so simple isn't it
it's it's and it's so witty and it's so
heartfelt it's not trying that hard
it's not trying that hard and and so
one day i was writing uh uh a song and
the
the opening uh verse sounded
just like a john prine song and i texted
it to him
and i i played it and sang it and i
texted it to him and i said
you want to write a john prine song and
he texted back
the first half of the first chorus and
then i texted back
the second verse and then he did uh the
second half of the second verse
and over two days we had written this
song over text message
that was 100 and you put it together
probably and send it back to him
yeah and like this is let's do this yeah
and we had such a good time we wrote
you know five or six more and then i had
a couple
that i had already written with other
friends and we put an album together and
we were playing shows around los angeles
you know a year and a half ago
when when the world shut down and uh
and so we we were gonna in the in the
hiatus between seasons i was planning a
tour we were gonna
go play shows and
none of that happened so so we finally
just released the record
and let people have a listen and and it
uh
yeah we're really happy with it i wanted
to play
uh a dawes song just a little bit
just to uh with the audience here i
think we could play it anyway right we
could play a little bit can't we
why don't you play joseph the spouse
song yeah why don't i do that
hold on that's a better idea what did
that name where did that name come from
um so yeah please interview him while
i'm doing this taylor
taylor and i were trying the the song uh
that i was just talking about it's
called deaf ears
if uh if you're looking for songs to uh
to insert
um taylor and i had been trying to
decide
he had been kind of consulting me i
obviously i didn't have a band really
i i didn't really feel like releasing
the record under my
own name um
because i i felt like it i felt like the
music deserved a character like it
deserved
a context outside of chris sullivan the
actor
um i wanted people to come to it
without that without that context and so
and so we had decided that
maybe a moniker would be appropriate and
and i was sitting in
an easter sunday catholic mass
i am not catholic my sister-in-law is
i love uh going to her church she has
this incredible irish priest
and father dhoni um
and they started listing saints and it
went on for a long time listing all the
saints
and it was all the ones you know saint
ignatius of loyola pray for us all these
all of these popular saints and then
they started getting into these more
rare sounding saints and one of them was
joseph the spouse and i didn't
one didn't realize that joseph of the
jesus mary and joseph
had been canonized as a saint
two i didn't realize that that he was
identified
for just being a spouse a spouse
and i thought that's an incredible
connotation for that
character and literally it's just a cool
it's a cool tie it just flows it's just
a character literature
who is recognized for being a witness
to a miracle yeah and
something about it struck me and i don't
know about you michael but when i'm when
i'm writing a song
i don't feel i feel like the song is
coming through
me it's not coming from me and i feel
like i am witnessing
a miracle especially when i get together
with other musicians
and everyone starts collaborating and
this song appears when it comes together
out of nowhere yeah it just becomes
something you couldn't imagine it is
something out of nothing
yeah it is sound out of silence and so
joseph the spouse was this
was this character who was this witness
to a miracle and that's
how i feel about writing these songs and
and i always feel like when i write
stuff
it you know i start mumbling things and
eighty percent of the words come from
mumbles
and the idea it's almost subconscious
yeah and so yeah the song
the first song taylor and i wrote is
called deaf ears collectors always find
my phone busy
cause it's been off the hook for 15
years
how much they want i cannot pay i don't
[Music]
i mean come on it's honestly beautiful
how do you not listen to that and go
that's just a gorgeous song thanks man i
appreciate joseph the spouse
uh what's the title of the album the
album is called six feet from under
six feet from under you gotta listen to
it please go to spotify go to itunes go
to wherever you get your music you're
gonna find it
uh this is uh [ __ ] talking with chris
sullivan right now this is these are uh
rapid fire these are from my patrons go
to patreon.com inside of you if you want
to join
i'll message you after nico p are there
any philanthropic organizations that are
near and dear to you that you can share
with us
yeah i work uh pretty closely with
a um a mental health organization called
to write love on her arms
um that helps connect people with
mental health services counseling uh
crisis hotlines
people are struggling with depression
suicide any of those things so i've done
a lot of work with them where can they
go
uh t w l o
h a dot com i like it emily s would it
if you like to go back to the set of
to film this is us um yeah probably
she really means after after being in
quarantine for so long i mean it was
it was stressful we were we were put in
these giant plexiglas
boxes and there were all of these we had
a lot of testing we got tested three
times a week monday we were
excited it was up then probably on
sunday a little bit a little bit but i
also knew
that we had all of the safety
precautions in place there were masks
and shields and
you know the only people without masks
were the actors and that was only
happening
you know between action and cut that
would give me
anxiety always having to wear a mask i
really am i always do
yeah but now you know backs but i it's
just
being on set yeah where it's like this
is my work this is
and wearing a mask the whole day and
then having going to your trailer
i think that's just yeah that was a lot
but we as a cast
were all on the same page so that gave
us all a good deal of confidence as far
as
you know staying quarantined staying
healthy right
staying because it would it could have
been a disaster and you didn't want to
be the [ __ ] that ruins it forever
seriously
dana dana asked if you had to have a
theme song playing when you walked
around
what would it be obvious child by paul
simon really yeah you know the song
yeah i do know the song i think mine
would be it's a mistake
from men at work
i think my dad would say that leanne p
now that things are opening up a bit
what are you looking forward to doing
mostly
um i am looking forward to traveling
we have uh rachel and i have uh a bunch
of family and close friends who uh
who we want to take bear to meet so
we're gonna
be traveling pretty soon i'm gonna come
visit bear yeah come roll around in the
backyard
oh yeah i'd love that dude i have to
yeah you look into his eyes michael and
you'll
you'll see what i'm talking what if you
just kind of overhear me and i'm just
holding him i go
you're the most important thing ever to
me there's nothing else that's
chris was right looking into your eyes i
know that you are the most
it's not having a baby that's not your
son that's not your kiss baby
this is the child maya p how has
becoming a father changed you've pretty
much said that yeah you've pretty much
discovered that mary b
rosie is blessed to have you as a friend
what word of advice is
what word of advice have you given him
that you really wish he would take to
heart
um i am blessed to have you as a friend
uh rosie just so everybody's clear wow
um ditto a piece of advice i mean what
what advice could i give you
we we live our lives uh
as an example of
i i try to live my life as an example of
what i hope
for the people around me not
in specifics not in i hope everything
happens the same way
but i
i try to deal with the difficult things
head on and i try to share them with my
share the way that i've dealt with the
difficult things with my friends
as as encouragement as encouragement and
you do it well to do the same
and it encourages you i i would say
ultimately
and it's just so cliche but honestly the
one thing that i'm learning is
you got to do whatever it takes to to
learn to love yourself
you've got to [ __ ] do it i have got
to learn
to just love myself and be the best
person i could be that that's it just be
grateful every day try to be grateful
i'm trying these aren't
when i say this this isn't me like i'm
grateful every day
and i am this is not me saying that this
is i'd like to love myself more i'd like
to
be more grateful i want to do these
things and i really am
trying to do these things there will
always be a balance and both things will
always be true and and i have days
when i really start to focus on the
things that i lack
right and it's and it's an awful [ __ ]
day
and a simple shift of perspective uh
towards the things that i have
and the blessings and the gratitudes
that i have
both things exist i lack things
and i have everything i need and it all
depends
it all depends on which um
which wolf i feed you know do i feed
the the wolf of of contentment or do i
feed the wolf of fear
and whoever i throw scraps to gets
stronger and gets louder
so yeah do you ever just like look at
bear and just
you just tear up yeah like i made this
almost
i told i told rachel yesterday i was
like
this is the best he's the best thing
i've ever done
and i and i did almost nothing
that's a line in a song right there he's
the best thing i've ever done he's the
best thing i've ever
it's almost ambiguous like what does
that mean yeah he's the best thing ever
and and i've tried hard
to create wonderful things yeah
and he's the the most wonderful thing
that i've created well
you're very important to me this has
been a blessing i love i love having you
here it's been too long and we've never
done the video so people can
watch they could listen it's good to see
you i'm glad you're happy i'm glad you
got a whole another season
yeah here i am thinking you're canceled
you're done you're like no we're filming
18 more episodes uh so that wasn't
exactly true
but uh thank you for sharing all this
with me
i really i'm very happy for you and
rachel yeah yeah that's great buddy
special to me you're special to me we
got that that was a text message from me
you
know it's what we it's what we talked
about with chris hardwick
that's what i'm saying yeah so it's it's
very hard to uh when you're talking to
someone in person
and just leaving going all right well
i'm gonna go now all right well dude
take care
blah blah blah so we just have a line
that just like you say it and then you
can [ __ ] off you just walk away
you're special to me and then you look
you just leave and then that's it that's
it
ryan you're special to me oh i leave now
yeah no no no
all right thank you for allowing me to
be inside of you chris as lovely buddy
felt good i love you man thank you felt
great
all right uh i love that man i love him
i love him dearly
sometimes you don't see people often
enough and then you see them and it
feels like yesterday
and it was beautiful having him in the
studio and talking about having a child
and
talking about his life and uh this is us
and the last season and
um it was always a joy always a real
joy having him around me he's a uh a
good spirit
good soul i love his to be in his
presence
so that's all i'll say about that like i
said covid
no joke uh i'm i'm doing a little bit
better um
just got some lingering effects and
trying to
they saw a uh there was a little bit of
fluid in the lung
in the left lung and but she wasn't
concerned about that and uh but i was
like holy [ __ ] man
you know i'm pretty healthy i uh it
doesn't matter
cove it's unpredictable
it could be perfectly healthy it could
be [ __ ] when it hits you
you don't know how it's going to hit you
till it hits you so
that's that that's what happened to me
you've heard many stories i'm one of the
millions of stories you've probably
heard
but all i would say is just uh just get
vaxxed why would doctors
why would doctors lie to you why would
doctors who since the beginning of time
have alway only tried to help you
i don't know i feel if uh yeah i'm not
gonna get into it we don't need to get
into it just
get faxed get faxed be safe be healthy i
don't want you to get
sick i hope you had a great week uh big
shout out to my
patrons i love you guys if you want to
join patreon and help the podcast in any
way
possible patreon.com inside of you
and uh i hope you do that i'll send you
a message like i always do right after
you
um join patreon we've got a lot of
members
some members get boxes sent to them from
me and messages and they get to ask the
guest questions and q and a's with me
and
tons of other stuff so if you if you're
digging the podcast you want to support
it more go to patreon.com
inside of you um also if you want merch
um
you know what let's just skip some merch
here let's let's do 15
off all merch why not wow i never do
fifteen percent off it's just called
rosie if we gotta we gotta come up with
a good name here because i don't know if
i could use that same name
rosie is fifteen how about that
r-o-s-e-y-i-s-15
rosie is
15. rosie is 15. i'm gonna have to i'm
gonna write that [ __ ] down
rosie is 15 off everything in the
inside of you online store there's
journals there's uh lex luthor pictures
there's small of a lunch boxes there's
tumblers there's
mugs inside mugs and uh tons of great
stuff
so make sure you go there and if you
want any sunspin merch go to
sunspin.com and you could book the band
you could book a zoom with me you could
do so many things
that you want to do all you want to do
is zuma zuma zoom zoom in the boom boom
i have nobody over here to laugh at my
stupidity ryan's not here today
as you know uh let's read the top tier
patrons who
really give a lot to the show and make
it possible so let's do that
nancy d leah s trisha sarah v little
lisa yukiko jill e bryan h
mama g nico p jerry w
robert b jason w apothean kristen k
emilia o
allison el raj c joshua d emily s cjp
samantha m jennifer n stacy l carly h
jen s jamal f janelle b carrie b tabitha
272 not to be confused with tablet 232
273. kimberly e mike eldon
99 more ramirez santiago am sarah f chad
w
leanne p janine r ray a maya p
maddie s shannon d matt w belinda n
kevin v
james r chris h dave h samantha s
spiderman chase shiela g brad
d ray h hi ray h hi tabitha t
tom n suzanne b liliana a michelle k
hannah b michael s talia m betsy d
betsy d claire m liz j
laurel chad l rochelle nathan e marion e
meg k janelle p trav and
dan and dan our last list right now here
we go
and i can't bank off ryan right now i
can't uh ask him you know what their
last name is
oh jeddah ojeda
did i say that wrong i know it's
something else isn't it
she could yell at me later oh jeddah
lorraine g veronica k big stevie w
kendall t carol d sandy b angel
m eric c rhiannon c stephen m cory k
super sam emily c
sherry s coleman g den
veksen dev vexin it's dev
vexen uh vixen dev
nixon michelle a liz l jeremy c andy t
cody r chris e sebastian k gavinator and
h david c elliott m john b brandy d
javore r and bono or bano
so there it is uh
thank you for listening today i love you
all very dearly
and uh thanks for all the get well
wishes it's been crazy man a little back
surgery and then it got covered
hopefully there's a light at the end of
the tunnel uh i hope you all have a
sensational week make sure you come to
the stage it
um this coming saturday 2 p.m 6 p.m two
shows you can get tickets at sunspin.com
or stage it
um and make sure you go to the inside eu
online store for 15
off rosie is 15 is the code rosie
is 15 for 15 off everything in the store
uh your dynamite thank you so much and
uh all my love to everybody
see you later from michael rosenbaum
alone in the hollywood hills without
ryan tayez
uh thank you for allowing me to be
inside of each and every one and i hope
you have a
glorious glorious day